a new cheating scandal is rocking Major
League Baseball the Houston Astros were
jubilant after their World Series win in
2017 but now league investigators say
the team was involved in an elaborate
spying scheme that year and well
Bojorquez is outside their stadium in
houston men well how long has this been
going on a good morning the Astros have
faced claims of cheating for years now
but a November report detailing
allegations from four former players
explained exactly how far the alleged
cheating went now the team manager and
general manager are both gone and Major
League Baseball is cracking down on the
organization we will always do the right
thing and will not have this happen
again on my watch
Astros owner Jim crane is adamant he
knew nothing about the cheating scandal
that led to some of the harshest
penalties in baseball history yesterday
after Major League Baseball detailed how
the team allegedly did it and suspended
two of the team's leaders manager AJ
Hinch and general manager Jeff Luna
Crane made the decision to fire them
both neither one of them started this
but neither one of them did anything
about it and that's how we came to the
conclusion here is how it allegedly
worked during home games the Astros
positioned a camera in center field that
camera would film signals given by the
opposing teams catcher about what pitch
the pitcher should throw that camera
feed was transmitted live into the
Astros dugout where a player would
allegedly be watching the feed with a
baseball bat and trashcan that loud
banging you hear would allegedly signal
to the Astros batter what pitch would be
coming next seemingly making it easier
to hit the ball you can see the pitcher
notices something is off
in that game Astros players allegedly
removed the monitor from the wall in the
tunnel and hid it in an office before
the game ended I think they're always
going to be people trying to bend the
rules to gain a competitive advantage
can dab it off is a baseball analyst for
the New York Post the idea was for this
to be a deterrent for teams to think
twice about allowing their their players
and their staff to do this kind of thing
no players were punished by the MLB in a
statement the former ghf Lou now said I
did not know rules were being broken AJ
Hinch said he did not endorse nor
participate in the practice but
apologized for failing to stop it
current Red Sox manager Alex Cora could
be the next to face punishment he's
alleged to have been the mastermind of
the tactic when he worked here in
Houston now the Red Sox have their own
investigation going we have yet to hear
from him Tony yeah this may not be over
Manny thank you very much but Manny
before you go if Thor ''tis believed
they were cheating do they still get to
keep the title apparently so
the official word right now is they
don't believe that changed the outcome
of they can't prove that it changed the
outcome of any of those games but of
course the fans will think very
different yeah if you're a Dodgers fan
you're not happy about yeah hard to
imagine it didn't affect the outcome if
you know a fastball is coming you can
hit it pretty far
you